so few weeks got a tough meeting with
somebody I've been mentoring for a few
years this is a person that was a
good-sized business but nothing's really
changed with him the last four years and
every time he's ever committed to any
number nothing's become a reality it's
just no one believes the words that
comes out of his mouth so he sits down
with me and he is going through sup and
I'm talking to him and asking questions
his wife is also sitting cuz they run
the business and at one point he asked
me a question says it doesn't sound like
you believe in me anymore
I said believe in you he says yes it
doesn't sound like you believe in me
anymore I said let me explain the
difference between believing in you and
what I'm about to tell you I absolutely
believe in you I believe the nuisance
you were doing nothing in the business
and you were very small and afraid and
insecure and doubted yourself I've
always believed in you I said I just
don't believe you anymore this is what
you mean I said you see believing in
something or someone is the possibility
of them one day being great or one day
doing something big for themselves right
that's believing in you but believing
you means I know when you say you're
gonna do something eight out of ten
times gonna get done and I don't believe
you cuz zero out of ten times it gets
done whatever you say it just doesn't
get done because your word no longer has
any weight and you have accepted making
commitments and not keeping up and
you're in the business world you don't
have to keep your word to anybody so why
would I mentor you the conversation led
to why would I mentor you why would I
sit down with you the last four or five
times we've sat down I don't need money
for the person who comes - oh my gosh
Patrick you're such a great lady I don't
need that act I don't need that words
for me but I'm just really wanted you to
know that I don't believe you anymore
and why is that
and you know his wife got emotional and
she started things up and he started and
being dependent said look there's no
more defending each other with this I
understand your main guys can defend
each other all you want I'm not trying
to take anything away from you I'm not
trying to
get anything from you I'm just telling
you I don't believe a single word that
comes out of your mouth I think when it
comes down to the business world I think
you guys are just be us and everybody
and so you listen to this message in
your life well Pat what does that have
to do with me like three days ago in
Cancun we're doing a leadership meeting
and I asked everybody had a few hundred
people here in Cancun we threw them out
I'm staying at this nice hotel Ziva good
times phenomenal times you got both
angles you both beaches you we got a few
hundred people here but I was having a
meeting with our guys three days ago
and I said I want you to take out a
paper and pen or your iPad's notes I
want you to make a list of people
outside of your business make a list of
people that you believe when they say
they're gonna do something they do it
make a list of them so everybody's like
looking I said what do you mean I said
look you want to get something done you
want to get something done and you need
somebody reliable who would you call to
get that job done so they start making a
list okay you know half the room
couldn't come up with five names it
couldn't come up with five names they're
like man I don't know I don't know what
could that says now now go to your
business who in your business that you
work with staff assistant executive
sales person it doesn't matter
make a list of the five people now when
they tell you they're gonna do something
they're gonna do whatever they can to
come through and they started writing
names they said okay this person that
person this person and then in the room
it's all the leaders few hundred of them
I said why don't you guys make a list of
people in this room who you believe when
they make a commitment who do you
believe here anybody started looking
around and it made the list now
obviously I don't ask him to say the
names but they a lot of them text it to
me right I said make the list and they
made the list
I asked said okay what does that make
you think when you make that list the
one with your family and friends people
outside of your business then the list
of five people you can count on then a
list of five people that you're working
with that are not working directly with
you they're your you know co-workers
you're your peers your you know
colleagues that you're working with
how's it feel with the list that you
have I don't know so how do you guys
think you're on other people's list what
do you mean there's a lot of strong
leaders in them that I know for back on
a lot of people's list some of you guys
are okay that you know others don't
fully know if they can rely on your work
to comfortable how do you feel about
that
I'm not good how do you feel about the
fact that you're on a list that people
can rely on good how do you feel about
the fact that you have those five names
you're on on a sheet of paper how do you
feel about them
very good so light is about being a
person that can be counted on and life
is about being a person with higher
volume of people that you can count on
because if you have a bigger block of
people that you can count on you can do
bigger mission and if you're on the list
of people more people who you're on
their block of people who believe that
they can get something done you're on
that list that's also a lot of
credibility because investment comes up
opportunity comes up you're one the
first people that gets a call it's not
just a problem you got to solve it's
opportunities that came in like what's
tonight we're thinking about doing this
and it's a quick opportunity to do this
do you want to be part of it put me down
great all we thought about was your name
here's what the other day I got a call
from a company that just got valued at
100 million 180 million dollars I
believe in a product great product they
made a phone call hey we know you
through XYZ and I was one of the guys
that got into the deal with a lot of a
listers I got into the list why because
they call there's a name there's a
reputation this guy can get it done it
you can call this guy he can do XYZ you
want to be a department during the time
I wasn't on this list there was a time
nobody called me so this isn't like me
talking at you as if all my gosh I know
it all and I mano Nera this is at one
point I wasn't and I want it to be this
is that if you notice the last couple
weeks messages if you didn't listen to
last week's message the most difficult
video you'll ever watch if you have a
one I'm gonna put the link over here you
need to go watch that as well because
it's very close to this one moral the
story it's difference between believing
in people and believing people and you
have in a block of business of people
that you can count on when they come
through
because their credibility scores very
high and you know many people's list of
people that they can count on you
because this is not just a business
thing this is family
this is relationship this is friendship
this is a kid
this is investors this is board this is
a lot of different things that you're
working with when people can count on
you and eventually you'll have a Rolodex
of people that if you one day want to do
something very very big I'm not talking
some small if one day you want to do
something very very big there are many
great lists and many people have access
to you and you have access to a lot of
people to say hey guys here's what I'm
thinking about doing what do you guys
think and they're willing to take your
call and they're willing to call you and
support you because your block of
contacts of people you believe in and
block up contacts of people that you
believe it's so big that you can go do
something very big for yourself that has
to be a mindset of a long-term thinker
that's not a year from that two years
from now that's ten years from that 20
years from now but most people don't
think like long term again if you didn't
watch last week's video the most
difficult video to watch click here to
watch that video and once you watch this
video I want to hear your thoughts on
what you pick there you've got away from
there you picked up from this video
comment below and again have a killer
week this week everybody talk to you
soon love you